now I heard that you were meaning to get
in touch with me but then I heard you
were dead
and I also heard that you were okay then
various other things but the fact is
Loki you and I are not the sword people
understand sword people fear now I got
the information that I needed now I have
to break your neck it's just the way it
is I'm not I'm just a messenger
[Music]
I'm dying
you should choose your words more
carefully
[Music]
no resurrections this time hey everybody
is Charlie you guys may have heard about
the infinity war and Avengers 4
producers talking about alternate
endings different versions of scenes
there's this big book coming out in
April that's the art of infinity war but
they're not releasing it till like right
around Avengers 4 drops in theaters
because there's a bunch of spoilery
things in it but in one of the excerpts
they've released they talk about deleted
scenes in an alternate ending for Loki's
characters that I'll explain just
because it definitively clarifies what's
happening in the theatrical version that
we saw there's a new round of that game
giveaway spider-man ps4 Red Dead
Redemption either one all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comments on the video uh
name a new winner at the end of this the
way the Russos and Tom Hiddleston
explained this scene as we saw it in
theaters is is it Loki's trying to
sacrifice himself in a last-ditch
attempt to try and trick Thanos so he
can kill him and stop all this bloodshed
from happening it's supposed to be this
really redemptive moment for his
character I'll play a clip from Tom
Hiddleston in a second where he
clarifies that just a little bit but
there was a producer in this big Marvel
art book that says that there was an
alternate version of this scene early on
where Loki was supposed to survive and
leave on some special escape pod before
Thanos showed up when they started
filming the scene where Thanos snaps
Loki's neck they said most of the crew
members were really confused because
they didn't have any of those pages they
were all expecting it to be the version
where Loki gets away on an escape pod
the reason why that's such a big deal is
because that clarifies that Loki really
was supposed to die in this moment
there's all kinds of theories about how
he'll come back how he'll trick people
because he is the god of mischief but
when the producers say there was a
version where Loki was supposed to
survive it implies that this is the
version where he dies more to that fact
this is a clip where Tom Hillston talks
about why this moment is so important
that he sacrificed himself and why it's
so important for his Redemption the
thing is that he he is redeemed and I
found it very touching because Loki as a
character has been so broken
for so long and no I think the center of
him has been very fragile and very
isolated after those traumatic events in
the first film when he finds out he was
adopted but not only Weig he was adopted
that his parents or his father had left
him to die so he has internalized that
shame of being abandoned and being alone
and and in all of that shame is turned
into something harder and angrier which
is why he becomes the villain he becomes
he becomes down to earth he tries to
subjugate it he becomes a villain in
every sense of the word he's motivated
by hatred and anger and then he loses
his mother and he's still kind of
unselfish and it's only the event it's
only losing his father who calls him one
of his sons Odeon includes him says are
my sons at the beginning of Ragnarok and
the chaos of another sibling it ain't no
hella turning up and sullen Thor and
Loki after join forces and and for
really gets through to Loki in that way
and so to have it all come full circle
and for Loki to call himself an odin son
to really identify with that to identify
with the strength of his father's love
before saving his brother I found really
touching doesn't Loki sacrifice in this
moment seem so much more important based
on the way Tom Hiddleston explains it I
think you kind of absorbed that in the
moment but the way he talks about it is
so utterly specific about how he chose
this family and it makes you feel birth
or without much more because he cared
about Loki that much so it's just more
confirmation that Loki in Avengers 4 is
gonna be an alternate version of the
character depending on which theory you
believe like either a straight-up memory
of someone because of be a are effing
technology from the original Avengers
movie a time-travel version from that
period or even a straight-up alternate
universe version no those are all
different theories that people have had
about the plot of Avengers
so it just depends on which one you
believe I mentioned it in another video
but a little kid at this same convention
straight up asked him if Loki died in
that moment just because so many people
have been asking him that this was his
answer I thought some amazing theories
about this I was in a park in London a
couple of weeks ago and some guys like
come and say hi and they asked me the
same question and they said listen they
said hey listen I don't know we need an
answer to this question all the other
times
Loki's died they've been a few he he
stabs with his right hand and now he's
stabbing with his left hand I was like
that's incredible attention to detail
was that were you aware of that detail
no the reason why he answers in that
funny way is because he actually starred
in scenes in Avengers 4 but he can't
really talk about those scenes and he's
not really sure about what the entire
plot of the movie is so I think that
genuinely he's not totally certain
what's going on with his character
although he does have that Marvel phase
4 TV series that they're developing for
the Disney streaming platform but they
haven't really said what time period
that's gonna be set during so early
theory about that is that it's set
during the past just so they don't
undercut this sacrifice in this moment
here like they really wanted this to
land and they don't want to roll it back
because of some funny twists in a future
movie so if you're really bummed that
Loki is dead in present day don't worry
Odin can communicate from Valhalla with
Thor so even in another plane of
existence Loki can still do that with
Thor whether or not you believe that
he's invalid is not Asgardian I feel
like if Marvel went so far to redeem him
in this moment and make him a part of
Thor's family they would also find a way
to bend the rules to get him into
Valhalla what's gonna happen next is
that they just dropped an extended
trailer for spider-man into the spider
verse with a couple really cool Easter
eggs so I'll do a video for that next it
should be up in the next couple of hours
one of the directors of Avengers 4 Joe
Russo was also doing
recent Q&A so if he says anything really
cool about Avengers for about production
or anything like that
I will totally make a video about it so
no worries congratulations Danny ben-hur
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my youtube channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for that new Captain Marvel teaser and
click here for the new Dragon Ball super
Broly trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]